DAVID GRINSPOON: Thanks a lot.
I'm going to talk for
just a couple of minutes,
and Alan will talk for
a couple of minutes.
And then we will
entertain your questions
and have a discussion.
It's a thrill for us
to be here talking
to you guys about this
book, "Chasing New
Horizon", and the mission,
and the effort that led up
to the mission that finally,
after a long journey, much
of which was spent on Earth,
we finally made it to Pluto.
And of course, Google is a part
of this story in various ways.
In fact, one of the
really cool things
that happened after, finally,
the success of the mission
was achieved and New
Horizons made it to Pluto
was that there was a Google
Doodle about the New Horizons
mission.
A really cool one
the next day was
part of the global
outpouring of interest
that reflected back on the
team that had achieved this.
And of course, the
connectivity of the world
that your company
has been so much
a part of is also an
interesting part of the story
because unlike other first
planetary flybys, historically,
that happened in the late 20th
century, the flyby of Pluto
happened in an age
where it could instantly
be shared and collectively
experienced around the world.
And it really made
the experience
different for those
of us who happened
to be there at the Applied
Physics Laboratory in Laurel,
Maryland, where the team was
controlling the spacecraft
and getting the data down first.
It made the experience
different there because there
was this reaching out to the
world and feedback coming back.
And of course, it
made the experience
different for people
around the world.
It was truly the first
21st century experience
of exploration
that was like that.
So this book, "Chasing New ",
is the story of how Pluto was
explored.
And a lot of it's
really the back story,
the aspects of
planetary exploration
and of this adventure,
this very human adventure,
that most people don't know.
Everybody knows we
made it to Pluto.
And like you said, in a way
it's like a spoiler alert.
On the cover of the book there's
a beautiful picture of Pluto.
So a lot of this is
the drama of will they
make it against all odds.
And then, of course, you
know how the story ends.
But it's like a lot of good
historical movies and novels
and stories.
Even though you know
how it came out,
you can still be on
the edge of your seat
with the drama and
all the close calls.
And that's the kind
of story we tell here.
I've been in love with
the story for a long time.
Way before there was a
New Horizons mission,
there was a small group, Alan
and some of his colleagues, who
were quite young
when they started,
just out of grad school
in their 20s and 30s,
who got this idea that
after Voyager made it
to Neptune, which was the last
of the sort of previous era
of planetary exploration.
After that in 1989, you
know, what was next?
We had had our first flybys
of all the classically known
planets except for Pluto.
And these guys said,
let's keep going.
And at first, they had a lot
of doors slammed in their faces
and a lot of doubters
and naysayers.
And then, as they
started going, there
were a lot of near calamities
and a lot of seeming dead ends.
But it's really a story of
overcoming obstacles and a team
that just got fixated on
an idea and didn't give up,
and eventually gathered
more and more people
to realize it was a
good idea, rallied
the scientific
community behind it.
And there's a whole story there
of how the skepticism gave way
to widespread endorsement.
And then there were a lot
of political intrigues,
and it was canceled by
two successive political
administrations.
26 years from when Allen started
working on this, got the idea
and started rallying
people together,
to the actual flyby of Pluto.
So you hear it took nine years
to cross the solar system.
And that is an
impressive time, and it's
longer than most of
our missions and did
require a lot of technical
innovation to succeed at that.
And yet that's like only a
small part of the long struggle
to make this happen.
So I was excited
to tell that story
and excited to work
with Alan, who lived it,
and work together to
combine our voices
and really try to narrate what
is essentially an adventure
story, sort of a techie, nerdy,
very human adventure story.
And it's not just Alan.
Want to make sure and
point out, he was obviously
the leader of the mission.
But there were a lot
of people involved.
As Alan says, it's a team sport.
And so we included the voices
of a lot of other people,
members of the science team,
engineers, some NASA officials,
different people that were
involved in this history
and in this mission.
So in the book, in
addition to our narrative,
you'll see a lot of Alan's
voice in the first person
sort of set aside
relating his experience,
but also a lot of other
voices kind of weaving in.
And you'll get to know
some of the characters.
So I've loved this
story for a long time.
When I got the opportunity
to actually work
with Alan on this book, it
was a dream come true for me
because I live to tell stories
of planetary exploration.
And in my view there's
no better story
in our time of exploration.
And then, of course,
Pluto itself turned out
to be just tremendous
scientifically, aesthetically.
It's beautiful, it's mysterious.
It's so much more active and
dynamic than anybody expected.
And that has taught us
a lot that we didn't
know about planetary science.
And it feeds back on
just our awareness
of what kinds of
planets there can
be in the universe in general.
So it was a huge payoff.
And the only person
who knows what
needed to be known to tell
this story, really, in full
is Alan Stern.
And it was a privilege
for me to get
to work with Alan to combine
our voices to tell the story.
And with that, I want
to introduce Alan
to come up and say a few words.
ALAN STERN: Sure.
[APPLAUSE]
It's great to be here.
Thank you, David.
I don't know how many
of you know this.
David is the best
writer in our field.
As a planetary scientist, no
one has written better books
from "Venus Revealed", about
the radar missions that
uncovered the geology of Venus,
to "Earth in Human Hands",
his most recent work
before "Chasing",
and quite a number of others.
And it's been a
privilege for me.
We've known each
other a long time
in a lot of different modes
over the years since we met.
He lived in Boulder
for a long time
and then in Denver,
where I'm based.
DAVID GRINSPOON: He
used to be my boss, too.
ALAN STERN: There's that, too.
That's true.
So this is a really
interesting story.
I hope you get a
chance to read it,
and I hope the people
watching on video
get a chance to read it.
When I was a boy I was swept off
my feet by the early planetary
exploration.
All I ever wanted to do was
grow up and get through--
I'm 11 years old, and just
the idea of going to a
is like light year
in the future.
I wanted to go to
college, and then I
found out you have to
go to graduate school.
And then I went to graduate
school four different times.
But at the time I emerged
in 1989 with my PhD,
Voyager was finishing.
And all the planets
from Mercury to Neptune
had been explored, at
least first reconnaissance.
Pluto was kind of unfinished
business and scientifically
fascinating.
We knew that it
had an atmosphere
and a giant satellite that
made it a double planet.
We'd never been to
anything like that.
We knew that its surface
composition was really exotic.
We knew a number of really
enticing, very basic facts.
But I think you could put them
all on a three by five card.
But to be a planetary
scientist at the beginning
of the age of space exploration,
the most prized missions
to be on were always
the first missions.
Only the best got to be
on the first missions
to Mars or Venus or Jupiter or
Mercury or on down the line.
And those are the missions
where scientifically
you can say the result is
like taking candy from a baby.
Everything, every
image, is just big news,
every spectra, every data type.
And for me, and
for my generation,
Pluto was the last
train to Clarksville.
It's like that's the only one.
When do we get a chance to be
on something that momentous?
And Voyager was just finishing.
And we thought, well, NASA's
in the exploration business.
This will be a cinch.
This will be a
15-minute conversation.
Who wouldn't want to
make the first mission
to the last planet?
And 14 years later we
finally achieved funding
after crazy experiences,
which you read about.
This book is really-- you
know, if you picture the DNA
double helix, picture like
a hecta helix or something,
because the book is the
political story of how this all
came to be.
And it's the scientific story
of why it was important to do
and how it was transformed by
the discovery of the Kuiper
Belt into being
the first mission
to the third zone
of the solar system,
and then these
fantastic results.
But it's also an under-the-hoof
look at how you build--
what we had to do was we had
to basically rebuilt Voyager
much lighter and much faster.
And you'll appreciate
this, I think,
because of some of
the projects you do.
We had to do it in half
the time and 1/5 the cost.
So we had to make a
lot of innovations.
Took 2,500 men and women.
I realize at Google, that's
a hobby shop project.
But a lot of people
worked on this,
and they worked very
hard, under the gun,
with what some
folks thought were
impossible boundary conditions.
I know when we won it, we
won it against the Goliath
of planetary exploration.
Our team wanted against
JPL, Jet Propulsion Lab
at Cal Tech, who had been
first to every planet
in the solar system.
We wrote the better proposal,
we marketed it better, we
did have the better team.
And NASA, I think, made the
right choice because I do
think--
it's uncertain to me whether the
other guys could have pulled it
off given all the constraints.
They were really old school
and we were new school.
But they were a talented
group, and I had many friends
on those competing teams.
Nonetheless, we got it.
And when we won it,
I can't tell you
how many phone calls
I got from friends
that were colleagues that
said you won, but you lost.
And that story is in the book--
David wrote it in the book--
because they'd say,
great, you've won.
You're now in charge of the
mission to Pluto that will
never get launched because
either you will fail
on schedule-- it
won't be your fault,
it will be some
vendor somewhere,
some critical part you need--
or you won't get
nuclear launch approval
because no one's done it ever
in four years, or even close.
That's 42 state and
federal agencies.
You guys use the phrase
we use about herding cats?
Yeah, this is different.
This is cats herding themselves.
It's a whole another level.
It's like
three-dimensional chess.
And then people
would say, what do
you mean, 20%, two
dimes on the dollar?
You're never going to figure
that out and get it done.
And one of these
traps will bite you.
You might get through
some of these hoops,
but you'll never get
through all of them.
And fortunately our
team was very dedicated,
dedicated to nights
and weekends.
The primary players were
Southwest Research Institute,
where I work, the
Applied Physics Lab, APL,
at Johns Hopkins,
and Lockheed Martin
for the launch vehicle,
the Department of Energy
for the nuclear power supply.
By the way, because
Google is a restaurant,
we used to call APL,
always a pizza lunch.
It's the only thing they
would ever serve, pizza.
The number of pizzas I eat
are in scientific notation.
Anyway, this book tells
all those stories.
And the stories
are woven together,
the science, the politics,
the how you build this,
how you fly an
interplanetary mission
across the solar system, some
of the technologies we invented,
like spacecraft hibernation,
the navigation requirements that
were super stringent, hit a
40- by 60-kilometer window
from three billion miles away.
And by way, do
that while arriving
within nine minutes
of the time you
aimed for when you
launched nine years before.
Do all that.
And you only get one shot.
There's no Voyager 2 here.
There's no New Horizons
2 to back it up.
There's no making a U turn.
We're going 4,000
kilometers a second.
Get it right or go home.
And it all worked out, although
we had a near-death experience,
which the book begins with,
July 4th 2015, a day meant
for other kinds of fireworks.
And my cell phone
rings, and I pick it up.
Even picking it up, I
saw it was the guy that's
our project manager.
And he's not calling
me on the 4th of July
because he's having
a great barbecue
and wants me to come over.
Before he ever got the
sentence through his mouth,
I could tell from the gravity
of his voice, he said, Alan,
we've lost contact
with the spacecraft.
That just doesn't happen.
It's not like when
your computer reboots.
It'll be fine in five minutes.
So it's a really
interesting read,
and I don't think there's
any book that's like it.
We were on the John Bachelor
Show in Manhattan this weekend.
And he kept saying,
you wrote a movie.
And we hope we wrote
a movie because it's
a really interesting story, and
it's not just for tech heads.
But it's also a story
of drama and persistence
by people with a dream
that actually managed,
despite a lot of
issues along the way,
to pull off what they didn't
know how to do when we started.
And I'd be happy to answer
questions if you have some
and talk about this.
But I want to tell one
story before I stop.
I've never told
this story before.
But I worked at NASA for a time.
And when I left--
this is NASA headquarters--
I ran the science program.
And that's a big enterprise.
It's about five and 1/2
billion dollars a year.
Not big by Google standards.
But I hadn't left about
10 days, and Eric Schmidt
invited me to come out to
Palo Alto to offer me a job.
And I said no,
which may have made
the difference between
whether we explored
the Pluto system or not.
I mean, in the end, thank
you, Eric, if you're watching.
The was a really enticing job.
But you know, I'll
be back on the market
after we finish exploring
the Kuiper Belt.
Anyway, so I thought I'd just
tell that little anecdote.
And then Dave, why don't
you come back up here?
And I don't know if--
the book's been out
less than a week,
so probably no one in
the room has read it.
But if you have any questions
about planetary exploration,
certainly astrobiology or
Pluto or the Kuiper Belt or New
Horizons, have at it.
DAVID GRINSPOON: I just have
to say one of the great things
about working with
Alan on this book
is that he got a lot
of great stories.
And the first step of us writing
this book together was we
talked every Saturday,
really, for a year and a half.
And he just told me stories.
And I asked him questions,
and we figured out
the structure of the book.
But I never heard
that story before.
That's a new one.
ALAN STERN: There
are a lot of stories.
DAVID GRINSPOON: Yeah.
ALAN STERN: We could have
written a 1,000-page book
and no one would read it.
DAVID GRINSPOON: What do
you guys want to know?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So obviously
there was a ton of buildup
to actually launching.
But once it actually launched,
what was that nearly a decade
waiting?
Like every day you have to
check in and make adjustments.
Or is it just it manages
itself and you just
stress for nine years?
Can you explain
what that's like?
ALAN STERN: The
most succinct answer
would be yes to
all those things.
It was intimidating to think
about nine and 1/2 years.
When we first launched it, that
just seemed to me like forever.
I mean, my 12-year-old's
going to be 21.
I can't even picture Jordan 21.
That kind of thing.
And I think all of
us felt that way.
One thing people don't know,
and the book does describe it,
is that while people think--
a lot of people know the
spacecraft was hibernating,
so they think we
were hibernating.
We had nothing to do.
But let me put this in context.
When Voyager flew
cross the solar system,
they had a staff of 450
people to run the spacecraft,
to do the science team,
to do the management,
to do everything.
My team was large when
we were building it.
But within a month of launching
it, we let everybody go.
We didn't need a launch
vehicle team any more.
We didn't need the
Department of Energy anymore.
We didn't need a
big engineering.
There was nothing left to build.
We just put a lot of spares
in controlled inventory,
and we had already done
all the documentation,
and we just kept some
engineering leads.
And so we were 50 people--
that's like the number
of people in this room--
to do every part of it,
from the flight controllers,
to the engineers, to the science
team, to the management team,
to the public affairs, all that.
And we were incredibly busy.
There's a chapter-- it's one
of my couple of favorites
in the whole book-- called
Battle Plan Pluto, where
we tell the story of how you
actually plan a flyby like this
where the spacecraft
is operating completely
by remote control.
All the software and
all the support files
have to be completely tested
in every way you can think of,
and how we had to plan four
flybys because we were worried
we would find hazardous
debris that could strike
the spacecraft on approach.
So we picked
different aim points,
and we could choose among them.
But the point at
which you would choose
was so close to
the moment of flyby
that you had to have the
software on the shelf.
There was no oh, now we'll
write a different plan.
Each plan takes like a
year to develop and test.
So we had to do this four times.
And on top of it, we
put intelligent software
up on the bird that could
detect 160 something faults--
the fuel is leaking
or the computer's
getting bad messages for this
or that, we lost com, whatever--
and then would run
down a checklist.
It could even, as it ran
down the checklist, decision
and branch based upon data.
So it would act as if you
had a crew member on board.
We had to write and
test all that stuff.
We conducted mission
simulations in which
we faked the clocks
out on the bird,
in flight, in the
middle of nowhere
between Uranus and Neptune.
It thinks it's 2015.
It's doing nine days
of every pointing.
We ship all that data back,
make sure every star field is
exactly the one you intended.
Every instrument was operating
at the right voltage,
every little thing.
We had 40 mission simulations.
The bottom line to all this--
and I'm only telling you part
of the story--
is we worked our butts
off for nine years.
Alice Bowman, the woman who
runs my mission control,
many times came to
me and said, there's
too much work for this team.
We have to take content out.
We've got to separate
icing from cake.
And she called it a nine
and 1/2-year sprint.
It was tough.
And the spacecraft
was hibernating a lot.
But this little team,
it was incessant.
And all of a sudden
Pluto was there.
And a lot of people were coming
and saying, wait a minute.
Can we put the brakes on?
I actually want to savor this.
It's coming too fast.
So thanks, it's
a great question.
DAVID GRINSPOON: And by the
way, the hibernation mode
that Alan mentioned was itself
a really innovative part
of this mission that was a
brilliant solution to how
do you have a spacecraft
traveling for nine and 1/2
years and not be worn
out when you get there,
and also have the human
resources to do all
that planning and simulating
that Alan was talking
about with a really small team.
It was part of how they
answered this question,
how do we do something on a tiny
fraction of Voyager's budget?
And a lot of them have
a smaller ground team
because they weren't running
the spacecraft the whole time.
But it was something they
had to learn how to do.
And we talk about
that in the book.
They practice
hibernation at first.
They put it to sleep
for a couple of days,
and then a week,
and then a month
to make sure that it works.
And that innovation, and
a lot of the other ones
they came up with, are now
part of space exploration,
and other missions
are using them.
ALAN STERN: I'll
just say one thing
and then I'll call
on this gentleman.
But [INAUDIBLE] asked
me before you all
came in the room
about how long it took
to get the data to the ground.
The dirty little secret is
we did it to save money.
We intentionally
chose that if you
could take nine
years to reach Pluto,
you could spend one more year
to get all the data back.
Voyager, with 70s
technology at Neptune,
almost as far as
Pluto, had ten times--
DAVID GRINSPOON: There's an
antenna right there behind you.
ALAN STERN: Little
two-meter dish antenna.
DAVID GRINSPOON: Small.
ALAN STERN: We had 1/10
the data rate of Voyager,
intentionally, because we
realized what an enormous cost
savings it was.
You say, well, how much cheaper
can a smaller antenna be?
It's not the antenna.
So how much cheaper can lower
powered transmitters be?
They save you
millions, but millions
is small in an 800 and something
million dollar project.
What it really was was
that if we had lower power
transmitters, I could graduate
down from two like Voyager
to one nuclear power supply.
And those babies cost
$80 million apiece.
So by accepting
lower data rates,
we made this very
intelligent compromise
that we would take a whole
year and a little more
to get the data back
in exchange for--
that's almost $100
million right there.
So there were a bunch of those.
And we talk about them.
Sorry for the detour.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In your opinion,
what was more significant,
the scientific
knowledge we gained
about Pluto or the
technological achievement
of having this kind
of incredible mission?
ALAN STERN: Oh, God,
which one of my children?
AUDIENCE: My own
personal thought is OK,
so it doesn't have, or does have
a core that is liquid or not.
Interesting piece of
information, but not
Earth-shattering.
But you know what
this mission entailed.
ALAN STERN: Yeah.
I don't think there's an
answer to that, actually.
Different people would
say different things.
And there's a third thing, too.
And actually, the book ends--
the last two and 1/2 pages is
a coda to the book--
that actually talks about the
biggest impact and the greatest
discovery was how much
it affected people, just
people, just inspired
people to STEM careers
and was a moonshot for a new
generation of millennials,
basically, and how
it affected them.
But all those things are good.
We don't have to
choose between them.
We got all the
scientific knowledge,
all the breakthroughs
in how you do low cost
spaceflight to the planets.
We got all the
engineering advances.
And we got all the inspiration.
So there's no
reason to rank them.
They're all great.
DAVID GRINSPOON: And you'd
never have one without the other
because without the motivation
for the exploration,
you're not going to
have a mission with all
that technical innovation.
But without all the
technical innovation,
you're not going to have a
mission and get the science.
But you know, it wasn't just,
oh, it has a core or something.
It actually was fundamental what
we learned there and changed
our paradigms and will truly--
it sounds like cliche--
but will truly require textbooks
to be rewritten because we did
not expect a small planet on
the fringes of the solar system
to be so geologically active
and diverse and vibrant,
and parts of it
to be quite young
and still currently forming.
And that was something we had
to go back to the drawing boards
and now have some
provisional explanations.
But that's really
what drives science
is this exploration that then
leads to results that shows us
that our prediction and our
previous knowledge was wrong
and requires us
to really reinvent
our theories of
planetary evolution.
And New Horizons has done that.
ALAN STERN: You
might imagine this.
But as a science team, everybody
wanted to make predictions.
And we actually
had a poll, and we
had a meeting a couple of
months before the flyby.
And one of my post-docs,
Amanda Zangari, ran the poll.
There were like 30 questions.
And we had a little team that
put together the questions.
Everybody answered them.
And we put the results in
the computer, of course
and we were plotting
the distribution
of the histogram of
how many satellites
do you think we'll find,
or how many people think
we'll find evidence for active
volcanism on the surface,
or whatever the questions were.
And then we showed
that to everybody.
And then, a couple of
months after the flyby,
when we had enough data
to sort of understand
the lay of the land, I scored
that against the real Pluto.
And it was pitiful.
And so I gave the team--
I literally passed
out report cards.
Yes.
And they gave all A's
for exploration and F's
for scientific
predictive ability.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Firstly, thank you for
the monkeys reference.
Is your subtitle optimistic
about first mission?
Or you know of upcoming
missions and planets?
ALAN STERN: Oh.
Well, both.
Both.
And we actually almost-- we
had a debate about whether--
I mean, there's more
been one mission,
so I would just say first.
It's just the epic
mission of Pluto.
Isn't that enough?
But first is one of those words
that it's like an SEO thing,
right?
It's going to get
people to look at it.
But we do expect that there
will be more missions because we
originally thought that we
could go in with 21st century
instrumentation and
accomplish, and we did,
about the equivalent of
the first 20 years of Mars
exploration in one fell swoop.
And we did.
But we learned many things
that make my head hurt.
And so we're working very hard
to see an orbiter fly there
and follow up.
And I think there'll be, now,
other missions to small planets
in the Kuiper Belt
because we want
to sample the diversity
of this new population.
I think if Pluto
is that interesting
and some of the things we know
from ground-based and Hubble,
soon we'll know from James Webb.
I think that we'll also
want to look at some
of the others for comparison.
So I expect there'll
be a lot more of this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: At the risk of being
a little bit obnoxious here,
I'd like you to weigh on
the merits of manned space
exploration versus
robotic space exploration.
And I ask this in
earnest because we,
living in a quasi-democratic
country, perhaps, as citizens,
get to weigh in on where
we put our dollars.
Do you think the public's
perception of this
is aligned with your
perception of this?
ALAN STERN: Well, that's
a different question.
But I will weigh in.
So you said weigh
in on the merits
of robotic spaceflight versus
human space flight Right.
So I might translate
that question
to an equivalent question.
Would you please weigh in for
me on the merits of a knife,
a fork, and spoon at the table?
My point is they're
all different tools
for different purposes.
And at the table, you
really need all three.
It's really hard to do
your soup with a fork,
and it's really hard to
cut your steak with just
the spoon or the fork.
And so human space flight
and robotic space flight
are really very different tools.
I don't know anybody
in this time that
would say you need
human space flight
to do weather satellites and
communications satellites
and a lot of the applications.
But it's still the case that
humans make much better field
analysis teams than the
rovers that we have now.
Apollo teams would cover about
as much ground scientifically
in a three-day expedition
as a Rover mission can
in five years.
And they can make on the spot
discoveries that robots can't.
So I think we need
all the tools.
And you know, we're not
going to be sending people
to Pluto anytime soon.
But on the other hand, at
places like the moon and Mars,
and maybe series and
smaller asteroids,
the humans can really push
the pedal to the metal.
And the humans do something--
even though New Horizons
was a good example of
being inspirational,
it's hard for the
23rd mission to Mars,
for that particular robot to
really light people's fire,
whereas when we
send men and women,
it will be unbelievable in
terms of the worldwide response.
And that's what fuels
the tech economy.
You know, space is the gateway
drug to engineering and science
careers.
Well, dinosaurs, too, but
dinosaurs always lose.
So it's really space.
Who else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How long did
it take after launch
for you to read a paper
or see a tech report
and wish that was
something you had had?
ALAN STERN: On board?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ALAN STERN: So we've
talked about that, too.
And so there are two
ways to look at that.
And the only realistic
way to look at it is,
given the boundary conditions on
money and schedule and the era
that we built it, between 2001
and '05, what would you do
differently?
That means a zero sum game.
You have to find the money,
the mass, the resources
by taking something else off.
And there's no instrument or
capability on New Horizons
that we wish we would trade,
that we would lose in order
to do something else.
Now with the Orbiter,
which will be
a much more capable spacecraft
and a much wider variety
of payloads,
onboard instruments,
we'll do lots of
things we couldn't
do with a simple flyby.
But I wouldn't trade If I
really could just have my wish,
it would have been that
we had enough money
to fly two because the far side
of Pluto and its satellites,
we can only see them from
millions of kilometers
away as we were screaming up,
and then they turned away.
And it's frustrating.
You look at the
other side of Pluto
and it looks completely
different and fascinating.
And what does that
have to teach us?
And I'm really betting
on life extension
so that I can BPI
that next mission.
Yeah, right here.
AUDIENCE: The mission was
a publicly funded success
at a time when it's not clear
what the future holds for that.
What do you think
is likely to happen.
What do you think should
happen in terms of public
versus private funding
for the [INAUDIBLE]??
ALAN STERN: Well, fortunately--
and everybody here probably
knows this-- is that commercial
space is coming on very strong.
And I admit I am
very highly biased.
And I also happen to be the
board chair of the Commercial
Space Flight Federation, which
is the industry federation
that Blue Origin and
SpaceX and everybody else
is in, 80 corporations, from
small mom and pop, almost,
shops all the way up to
SpaceX and Blue Origin.
But I think, again,
it's not a choice
between one and the other.
This is a huge solar system
with dozens of worlds.
And I don't know how we would
do all the things that we
do on the seas and in the air if
it was all done by just the Air
Force and the Navy.
And besides that, if
it's one organization,
you can't possibly have
the level of innovation
that you get
through competition.
And so I think all that's going
on at places like Blue Origin
and SpaceX and all the
others is it's finally
the 21st century, where we don't
just have one space program,
but lots of them.
And now we're starting to
have the asteroid miners
and the moon miners and
lots more applications being
talked about.
I think the 20s are going
to be just spectacular.
But also what NASA is going
to be doing in the 20s,
which you would not see
commercial enterprises
exploring Europa for
scientific knowledge.
But you might see
commercial enterprises
sending payloads to Mars
because they can find customers
that want to fly those.
So sort of the vanguard,
the leading edge, I think,
is always going to be the
government in most respects.
But private industry is what
comes in and really turns it
into part of the
economy and what we do.
And we need both.
DAVID GRINSPOON: And nobody
at NASA that I know--
we both know a lot
of people at NASA--
nobody there is bummed
out that oh, now we
have these competitors
from private industry.
They're like, oh, great.
We don't have to be
the trucking service up
to orbit, or the bus service.
We can focus on other things
that only NASA can do.
And so the private
public partnership
is really being sought by
both sides in that equation
and is shaping up to really
accelerate space exploration
in this century.
ALAN STERN: Yeah.
And Jim Bridenstine, who's
the new NASA administrator,
really gets it with public
private partnerships.
I think he's going to be great.
I'm left-handed, so
I've been biasing
to this side of the room.
Is there any question over here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this is not the
only recent exploratory mission
to an icy body in
the solar systems,
because we also had the
Rosetta probe to the comet.
I was wondering if there
is anything especially
in the astrobiology sector,
maybe, that stood out,
like that was
either surprisingly
different or surprisingly
the same between and Pluto
and the comet, whose
name I've forgotten?
ALAN STERN: Well, can I just
say Churyumov-Gerasimenko.
DAVID GRINSPOON:
Very nicely done.
ALAN STERN: Well, I was on the
Rosetta mission for 22 years.
We do call it C-G.
It's too much.
DAVID GRINSPOON: So
Alan can probably
comment in a more sophisticated
way about the comet
since he was on that mission.
But I will say, from an
astrobiology perspective, one
of the amazing things
about New Horizons
and Pluto is the
evidence that there
is an ocean of liquid water
beneath the icy crust of Pluto.
It seems like there's
circumstantial evidence
that there are features
of the planet that
are easiest to explain if
there is a liquid water ocean.
And one of the things
we would definitely
want to do with this orbiter
Alan is talking about
if we go back is map
the gravity field
and do other things
to really make sure we
understand that that's true.
But it's seeming like there is
an ocean of liquid water, which
is amazing from an
astrobiology perspective
because any place where
there's an ocean of water
is a candidate for
extraterrestrial life.
So just as you've heard
about Europa and Enceladus
as possible homes for
life underneath the ice,
we really have to add
Pluto to that list now.
ALAN STERN: Yeah.
And keep in mind--
so I PI of the ultraviolet
spectrometer on Rosetta.
So we won that project
in the beginning in 1996
and the flight
mission ended in 2016.
And actually, the data
analysis part of the project
is still ongoing.
But you know, the comet C-G,
the one with all the syllables,
is about the size
of Cambridge, Mass.
And Pluto's the surface
area of the United States.
So it's a different
scale, and the kind
of science you're doing
is very different.
Who else?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: What was the biggest--
what was the most
frustrating mistake
that you look back on of,
oh, we didn't do this right.
If I could go back
and change one thing.
What was the biggest takeaway?
ALAN STERN: Wow,
that's a good question.
I ought to say the
thing that nearly killed
the spacecraft 10 days out.
But it sure brought
a lot of viewership.
The last minute, all of a
sudden it's life or death.
DAVID GRINSPOON: There
were some other mistakes
that we describe in the book.
But fortunately none
of them were fatal
because we have a success story.
But they're illustrative.
I mean, one thing you learn
in this book is how carefully
everything was checked by
independent teams, and just
a lot of amazing
troubleshooting.
And very little slipped through.
But there was one
spreadsheet where
one thruster had the wrong
specs and was built and flown
with the wrong
specs so that it was
going to fire too many times
and exhaust its lifetime
before they got to Pluto.
And they discovered this
when they were in flight.
And they were able to
make some workarounds.
But that was sort of
almost the exception
that proves the
rule because there
was almost nothing like that.
But it was really
illustrative of why
it was so important that they
do all that ridiculous amount
of checking and double checking
because so little slipped
through.
But that was maybe
not the worst mistake,
but it's an
illustrative mistake.
ALAN STERN: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I really don't
have a good answer
because most of the things
that I think I did wrong
or we did wrong actually, in
the end, worked out better.
So for example, if I could do
it again, some of the things
I was doing in the
90s to lead the effort
to get a mission to
Pluto, I think now,
with more experience, I
could have made it happen.
But then I would have
just been a bit player
on that mission instead of being
able to lead the whole thing.
So I don't want to
make that happen.
This was a lot more fun.
Yeah, you go.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
with regard to [INAUDIBLE]..
A lot of the story here
revolves around politics
and political struggle.
And I was wondering, the fact
that Pluto, at some point,
was demoted, was it part
of a political game?
How could you explain it?
ALAN STERN: I don't think
it was a political game.
There are really two
things that were going on.
One is, I think, appreciated
by a lot of people, which is--
I think especially here,
you have the sophistication
to know astronomers are
not planetary scientists.
Different expertise.
When I give a public talk, I say
neurologists and podiatrists.
Don't go to one for a
problem with the other.
Different expertise.
But people in the public,
including my own mother,
confuses that all astronomers
must know everything
about everything in space.
They were really trying to cope
with large numbers of planet
discoveries and thinking
in a 20th century way,
I would say, that
the number of planets
should be small
so schoolchildren
can remember their names.
I wish that they'd just
been consistent and gone on
and had motions they'd
voted on other things they
don't know about, and just
gone ahead and legislate it.
We're only also going to have
eight elements and eight states
now.
But they didn't.
So the press picked up on it.
And the press, also naively,
took it as expertise
and sort of made
it a fait accompli,
when people like David
and myself and others
in planetary science,
a joining profession
of a different expertise, never
said that, and don't buy it,
and don't even buy
the idea of voting
in science because it's sort
of an illegitimate process.
We could all vote that the
theory of evolution is wrong.
It doesn't matter how many
Nobel Laureates vote for it.
That doesn't mean that the data
doesn't support the theory.
The other thing that was going
on-- and it's very rarely
discussed-- but it's the fact
that in 1980, an astronomer
named Brian Marsden, who
was very accomplished,
had a very public with
the man who discovered
Pluto named Clyde Tombaugh.
And he actually
said at a meeting
in front of a lot of people,
you're older than me,
and when you're gone, I
will erase your legacy.
And Marsden is the person
that led the IAU week
to pass that resolution
which took Pluto
off the astronomers' list.
And so there's a
lot of bad blood.
DAVID GRINSPOON:
Yeah, and if you
look at the specific technical
description in the IAU's
attempt at redefining
planet, just
from a scientific,
quantitative perspective,
it doesn't make any sense.
They did a sloppy job.
Well, for one thing, they said
a planet has to orbit the sun.
They ignored all the
exoplanets, which is ridiculous.
But also even within
our own solar system,
they had this
criterion that a planet
must-- supposedly they said
it must clear its zone.
So they defined
a planet in terms
of what orbits around it and not
its own intrinsic properties.
And that leads to some very
silly, absurd conclusions,
like that Earth was not a planet
for its first 500 million years
because it was orbiting in a
swarm of material left over
from the formation of the sun.
And if you took Earth today
and moved it somewhere else,
say out in the asteroid
belt or something,
it would not be a planet.
So there are a lot of just
sort of unsatisfying aspects
of the definition.
So it certainly
made sense to them
to talk about classifying
Pluto and other small planets
like it as a different subclass
of planets, dwarf planets.
That's fine.
But then they sort
of added this,
and a dwarf planet
is not a planet.
And it was kind of
vindictive and nonsensical.
And so in planetary
science, at our meetings,
you'll hear us referring
to Pluto a planet.
And we almost kind
of don't really
even want to talk about
this, except for it is worth
talking about because
people are confused,
and they want to know.
And so we have to
try to clarify it.
ALAN STERN: He said we
don't want to talk about it.
But yesterday in "The
Washington Post", the two of us
had an Op Ed.
DAVID GRINSPOON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how many plants
are there on your list?
DAVID GRINSPOON: Uncountable.
ALAN STERN: So yeah,
that's really the answer.
Oh, known?
It's in the mid 20s.
DAVID GRINSPOON: In
our solar system.
ALAN STERN: In our solar system.
But of course there are
thousands of known planets
around other stars.
But you know, who cares?
There's countless mountains
and rivers and stars
and asteroids and galaxies
and all those things.
Space is all about, oh,
astronomical numbers.
So we really need to
get over the notion.
The notion that there were
a small number of planets,
I think, is
equivalent to somebody
who grew up on a
desert island where
there were a countable
number of palm trees.
And you think that's
it for the world
because you don't see
any other islands.
They're all over the horizon.
Then you develop the
technology for ocean travel,
and you can now go
to other places.
And you discover that all those
trees, you gave them names.
There's so many you
can't name them all.
So you decide those
aren't actually
palm trees for whatever
reason, just to keep it small.
So it's kind of crazy.
OK.
I guess we're going to say thank
you for coming out at lunch.
[APPLAUSE]